[Música]
hola soy mátala cabrera y les doy la
bienvenida aquí américa el espacio de
france 24 para revisar en profundidad
las historias de nuestro continente
en chile el arte callejero fue censurado
así se veían en 2019 los muros que
acompañaron el estallido social y así
están ahora los mensajes se
desvanecieron en medio de las medidas de
la cuarentena
y los índices de mortalidad en eeuu
revelan que las minorías étnicas son las
más afectadas por el coronavirus
especialmente los latinos y los
afroamericanos revisamos la situación en
san francisco
en la recta final para las elecciones
presidenciales en eeuu en latinoamérica
les tenemos un segmento especial sobre
los temas clave de esta contienda entre
donald trump y joe biden por la casa
blanca hoy hablamos de la pandemia del
cob y 19 en la unión americana
y vamos de inmediato a santiago para
nuestra historia principal el gobierno
de sebastián piñera aprovechó los meses
de pandemia para borrar muchas de las
expresiones artísticas del estallido
social y recuperar la plaza italia que
fue el epicentro de las protestas
también lo hizo el congreso que aprobó
varias leyes que podrían penalizar a los
artistas callejeros y brindar al
ejecutivo de posibles responsabilidades
en las presuntas violaciones a los
derechos humanos ocurridos entonces el
informe desde nuestra corresponsal en
chile patricia luna
cuando empezó la pandemia del cob y
éstas eran algunas de las huellas que
las protestas de octubre dejaron en las
paredes de santiago hoy estos muros han
sido limpiados entre ellos las obras de
callo chama uno de los artistas visuales
más conocidos durante la revuelta
aquí y aquí ya está todo el día desde
llegar hasta acá
y ahora ya como ven no hay nada todo
está todos los mensajes hay ocultos
atrás de esto esta capa de pintura
es parte de todo lo que nos borraron a
todos los artistas
que llenamos acá tuve al frente de un
lado está todo gris
el gobierno chileno aprovechó la
pandemia para borrar los símbolos del
estallido social restaurar el mobiliario
de plaza italia el lugar emblemático de
las manifestaciones y poner una guardia
durante 24 horas en los monumentos que
habían sido tomados en el congreso
avanza un proyecto la ley stickers que
sancionará con multas y penas de cárcel
a las personas que pongan pegatinas en
el mobiliario público o transporte entre
otros y que podría hacer que calles como
ésta ya no se vean más evidentemente es
un ataque a una de las expresiones con
más sencillas y cotidianas justamente de
la protesta de lo que significa el
expresarse y el expuesto a ciertas ideas
en un transporte que llama es pobre
además el gobierno envió un proyecto de
ley para regular la cooperación con la
corte penal internacional haciendo
cambios que podrían implicar el blindaje
del ejecutivo ante las posibles
responsabilidades por las violaciones de
derechos humanos ocurridas el 18 de
octubre para los artistas la lucha sigue
y para calles llama no hay arma más
poderosa que su arte ya me lo tomé muy a
pecho de comunicar de mostrar lo que
está pasando y esta es mi manera de
hacerlo y si me dice medianamente presa
o me van a multar y todo bueno tendré
que
que asumir las consecuencias pero voy a
seguir igual que igual que siempre y
creo que todos los artistas que estamos
en esta pensamos igual y como muestra
[Aplausos]
y vamos a colombia para revisar otras
noticias del continente esta semana
los dos policías involucrados en la
muerte de javier ordóñez que desató las
protestas que derivaron en más presuntos
abusos y la muerte de al menos 13
personas fueron detenidos y enfrentan
cargos de tortura y homicidio agravado
claudia lópez la alcaldesa de la capital
bogotá
responsabilizó a los policías de las
muertes mientras que el presidente iván
duque es blanco de críticas por utilizar
un uniforme de la policía en medio de
los reclamos sociales
y la misión de la organización de
naciones unidas en venezuela concluyó
que el gobierno de nicolás maduro es
responsable de violaciones de derechos
humanos
el explosivo informe señala a maduro al
número 2 del chavismo diosdado cabello y
al menos otros 50 funcionarios de ser
responsables de delitos de lesa
humanidad desde 2014 el canciller jorge
arreaza rechazó las conclusiones del
informe que asegura responden a
ideologías políticas
tiene años renunció a ser candidata a la
presidencia de bolivia para las
elecciones del próximo 18 de octubre la
mandataria interina aseguró que con la
decisión espera que el voto opositor a
evo morales- de una en una sola
candidatura y es que el candidato del
partido del ex presidente el movimiento
al socialismo más
luís arce está liderando las encuestas
de intención de voto
y seguimos hablando de kobe 19 como
sabemos cualquier persona puede
contagiarse pero los índices de
mortalidad en eeuu revelan que son las
minorías étnicas las más afectadas por
el coronavirus especialmente los latinos
y los afroamericanos pero no se trata de
que sean genéticamente más susceptibles
sino que se exponen más y no reciben la
atención médica apropiada para entender
por qué la universidad de california se
asoció con una organización latina las
conclusiones nos la cuenta nuestra
corresponsal en san francisco susana
mendoza
ante el cob y no todos somos iguales al
menos eso parece haber demostrado el
estudio unidos en salud de la
universidad de california en san
francisco y la organización latino
taskforce fue un estudio que tomó cuatro
días estuvo al final de abril e hicimos
es prueba zar cuatro más de cuatro mil
personas de esas cuatro mil personas
nada más 74 en este momento sólo 74
volvieron positivos de esas 74 95 todas
eran latinas susana rojas de latino
taskforce junto con médicos de la
universidad de san francisco decidieron
ampliar el estudio tras ver estos
resultados
necesitamos más casting como están
viendo ahorita más pruebas como estaban
viendo ahorita necesitábamos dinero para
las personas que tienen miedo de hacerse
la prueba porque no pueden pagar la
renta no pueden dejar de trabajar
al miedo a perder el trabajo se suma la
situación migratoria
elida lópez y su cuñada desconfiaron al
principio estamos emigrantes
tenemos miedo de que por medio de esto
de la información que uno da se entere
todo el ser más el gobierno y entonces
está el miedo que uno tiene y por eso no
lo habíamos hecho los médicos entienden
ahora porque hay mayor prevalencia del
virus entre latinos
en the life
en el día a día la probabilidad
interactuar con el virus es mayor sobre
todo porque participan
desproporcionadamente en servicios del
sector servicio
y mucha gente no tiene ese privilegio de
refugiarse en casa
de no hablar western place gracias a
este estudio muchos hispanos en san
francisco pueden ahora a recuperarse con
tranquilidad la ciudad de san francisco
otorga dos semanas de salario mínimo
para hacer cuarentena sin importar el
estado migratorio empezamos nuestro
segmento especial de aquí a américa
camino a la casa blanca el espacio para
revisar los temas clave de esta
contienda entre el presidente de donald
trump y el candidato demócrata joe
bayrén de cara a las elecciones del 3 de
noviembre hoy vamos a hablar del cobi 19
con más de 6 millones y medio de casos
confirmados y casi 200.000 muertes eeuu
es el país más afectado del mundo por lo
que desde luego la crisis sin
precedentes marca la campaña
presidencial
las medidas de confinamiento causaron
inmensos estragos en la economía y según
la reserva federal habrá una contracción
del 3 7% de este año por lo que se ha
hecho una prioridad para trump el
hallazgo de la vacuna perfilándola como
la solución definitiva el jueves el
mandatario insistió en que la inyección
iba a estar lista en octubre en
contradicción al centro para el control
de enfermedades de hecho la revista
science- ific american que en sus 175
años de historia nunca había tomado
partido por un candidato presidencial
respaldo a joe biden en su editorial
señaló que trump ha hecho daño a los
estadounidenses por su respuesta que
calificó de inepta a la pandemia
y debido a las críticas por negar los
hechos científicos el mandatario tuvo
que matizar sus declaraciones el viernes
y dijo que la distribución masiva de la
vacuna llegaría en abril
habremos fabricado al menos 100 millones
de dosis de vacunas antes de fin de año
y probablemente muchas más cientos de
millones de dosis estarán disponibles
cada mes y esperamos tener suficientes
vacunas para todos los estadounidenses
en abril
y por supuesto el candidato demócrata
joe fue uno de los críticos escuchemos
el propio director de los cdc lo
contradijo recientemente dijo que si de
hecho sólo usaba esta máscara nada más
que esta máscara salvaría a otras cien
mil vidas entre hoy y enero por lo que
tenemos que ser honestos con el pueblo
estadounidense
así que la idea de que habrá una vacuna
y que todo estará bien mañana no es
racional no es razonable vamos a hablar
en miami con nuestro corresponsal
anthony welsch antonio y la vacuna se
está presentando como el elixir que
solucionaría la crisis entienden los
electores estadounidenses que el acceso
a la vacuna no depende de quien esté en
la oficina oval
así que muy buenas tardes pues lo cierto
es que no se sabe si la gente es
consciente de que esa decisión para
lanzar la vacuna no depende de la
administración de turno que ocupa la
casa blanca sino que es un trabajo
reservado a los científicos el mismo
presidente tal y como lo habíamos
escuchado ha dicho que a mediados de
abril está previsto que todos los
estadounidenses que lo requieran podrán
acceder a la vacuna una afirmación que
contrasta con lo que dice la
administración de alimentos y fármacos
la fed y los centros para el control y
prevención de enfermedades que dicen que
hay que tomarse ese tipo de afirmaciones
con muchísima más cautela y precaución
porque hay que hacer muchísimos más
ensayos para asegurar la efectividad de
estas dosis y en este caso qué
importancia tiene la el apoyo de la
comunidad científica al joe valdez
de hecho cada vez hay más voces críticas
de expertos médicos científicos que
están trabajando en los laboratorios
aquí en eeuu recordemos que hay dos
laboratorios que están trabajando por
esta vacuna aquí en el país
norteamericano por un lado está a facer
y modernas que están pidiendo a la
administración al gobierno
norteamericano que pues moderen bastante
más esas palabras porque dicen que se
está convirtiendo en un tema de campaña
la cuestión de la vacuna y por supuesto
donald tran no quiere dar su brazo a
torcer siempre que puede estar hablando
de ese posible el lanzamiento cuanto
antes de la vacuna de la cob y de 19 él
sabe que es un tema importante y que en
eso también está su victoria o no las
próximas elecciones gracias a nuestro
corresponsal en miami anthony welsch y
por su intervención en este segmento
especial de aquí américa camino a la
casa blanca y a ustedes gracias por
acompañarme en esta emisión recuerden
que pueden seguirme en
sociales en la dirección que ven en sus
pantallas cuídense mucho del coronavirus
y sigan viendo france24
[Música]
versalles